تعرض الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون لموقف محرجا
بعد ان ساله شاب مصاب بالتوحد عن علاقته
بزوجته وكيف ارتبط بها وهي معلمته اكبر
منه ب 24 عاما وذلك خلال جلسه مع محاولين
من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه وقال الشاب
للرئيس يجب ان تكون قدوه ولا تتزوج معلمتك
لنشاهد ماذا رد ماكرون
[موسيقى]
غريب وقت الموضه
ههه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قد يفتح خلال الرحله في الجو هذا ما عاشه
بالفعل ركاب طائره روسيه بعد ما فتح باب
خلفيه للطائره التي كان علامتها 25 من
الركاب بينما كانت تقلع من ابرد منطقه في
العالم ما تسبب بالتطاير بعض الامتعه ولم
تعلن السلطات عن وقوع اي اصابات
[موسيقى]
تداول ارواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لمشهد غير مالوف لجبال مكه المكرمه
وهي تكتسب اللون الاخضر بعد الامطار
الغزيره التي شهدتها المنطقه مؤخرا
[موسيقى]
شهداء مجلس النواب الاردني واقعه مضحكه
لمداخله النائب محمد العلاجمه بعد سخريه
من وزير الماليه محمد العسيس وعوده بتحقيق
نمو المرتفع لموازنه العام الجديد
الوزير بيعان في الموازنه السابقه اذا
حققت نسبه النمو 2.5% سوف احملك على
اكتافي من خارج واذا تتذكرها وادخل بك
لهذه القبه ولم تلحقه واليوم اذا حققت
نسبه النمو هذه انا بدي ازوجك واحده من
خالاتي اللي مكمل مجازه
شو هالحكي
[تصفيق]